[Música]
llegó el momento hablar de economía en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge feliz
viernes pero a ti muy buen día vamos a
empezar hablando de la economía en
europa así es que pese al aumento de los
precios del gas y la electricidad en ese
continente el producto interno bruto
mostró una leve mejoría el pib del
eurozona creció un 2,2 por ciento entre
julio y septiembre en comparación con
los meses previos mientras que la unión
europea el incremento trimestral fue de
2,1 por ciento ambos índices subieron
una décima por encima del registro del
segundo trimestre del año aquí hay que
hacer una aclaración raúl y es que los
términos
europa por ejemplo como continente está
conformado por más de 50 estados de
estos no todos pertenecen a la unión
europea la unión europea está formada
por 27 países como alianza pero no todos
los estados que componen la unión
europea pertenecen a la llamada eurozona
la unión europea es una unión económica
y política entre países mientras que la
zona del euro es una unión monetaria
allí los restos y los restos son
bastante grandes según adelantó
christine lagarde quien es presidenta
del banco central europeo escuchemos
news ricauter spanglish la zona del euro
sigue recuperándose con fuerzas aunque
el impulso se ha moderado en cierta
medida los consumidores siguen teniendo
confianza y su gasto sigue siendo fuerte
pero la escasez de materiales equipos y
mano de obra están frenando la
producción en algunos sectores
y
la inflación está aumentando pero sobre
todo por el aumento de los precios de la
energía pero también porque la
recuperación y la demanda están
superando al escaso ofertas 'recovery'
in the mount es out pacing constraints
supply re volvamos a las cifras en
comparación con el tercer trimestre de
2020 el aumento del pib fue el 3,7 por
ciento en el área de la moneda única y
del 3.9 en el conjunto de los 27 países
que antes aclaramos esto el principal
aumento trimestral del pib entre julio y
septiembre se registró en austria
seguido de francia y portugal mientras
que la tasa más baja se observó en
letonia el aumento trimestral del pib
tanto en la unión europea como la
eurozona fue superior al registrado en
países como eeuu y china que son grandes
economías así es jorge vamos ahora con
otro tema no en francia la economía
mostró muy buenos resultados así esa
economía creció alrededor del 3% en el
tercer trimestre según los datos
preliminares este crecimiento fue
impulsado por el aumento del gasto de
los consumidores y las exportaciones
muestran como la segunda economía de la
zona euro se recupera de la pandemia el
ministerio del ministro de finanzas
bruno le maire dijo a radio france-info
que la cifra era un resultado
excepcional la agenda en la agencia
nacional de estadística de seguro que el
crecimiento del tercer trimestre
significa que la economía francesa
estaba cerca de volver a su nivel previo
a la pandemia pero los analistas del
banco de inversión e ing advirtieron que
podrían representar un pico para este
año y que la economía mundial lucha
contra las preocupaciones inflacionarias
y los problemas de la cadena de
suministro según el banco a partir de
ahora el crecimiento económico en
francia empezará a ralentizarse el
aumento de los precios de la energía en
octubre hizo que la tasa de inflación
subiera al 3,2 por ciento jorge ya hay
preparativos para la reunión del g20 no
que comienza en italia así es y bueno en
momentos en que crecen también los
temores por la hiperinflación y los
problemas globales de la cadena de
suministro se esperan muchas reacciones
durante esta reunión se suma a la
discusión el cambio climático estos
líderes representan regula las economías
del 75 por ciento de las emisiones
mundiales de carbono y son consideradas
armas para evitar otra catástrofe en
este caso la catástrofe ambiental
la primera vez que se ven en dos años en
persona el año pasado la cumbre fue
virtual como recordarán y los temas más
relevantes serán la crisis energética
que estimula la inflación aumenta los
precios de los combustibles los
servicios públicos nuevos productos de
kobe 19 y retrasos en las cadenas de
suministro los funcionarios de salud
economía reunidos en roma se van a
reunir en roma' este viernes luego los
presidentes y primeros ministros el
sábado del domingo aunque los
representantes de las principales
actores económicos como rusia y china no
estarán allí en persona ore a
indicadores económicos arrancamos en
asia el hang seng cerró con pérdidas en
una sesión en la que los inversores
parecieron poco entusiasmados al igual
que ayer y en europa las tecnológicas
arrastraron a las bolsas europeas luego
de la malos datos de amazon y apple
mientras los inversores seguían
nerviosos por las perspectivas de la
política monetaria la cifra del día
jorge la cifra del día en las acciones
de apoyo de amazon van a perder más de
180 mil millones de dólares de valor de
mercado combinado después de que
avisaran de un déficit en la temporada
navideña y presentarán malos resultados
y nos vamos a turquía georgia porque ahí
se desarrolla nuestro reportaje de hoy
vamos y nos vemos luego
[Música]